the universe has been expanding since
its birth gradually burning through the
fuel that lights its stars but what
happens when the fuel runs out will it
all just fade away stars die out use up
their nuclear fuel we have an empty cold
desolate universe just dead remnants of
stars black holes neutron stars
eventually they decay away and you're
left with a thin haze a very low-energy
light that's it we used to think the
universe would cruise gently into old
age but over the past few decades
astronomers have revealed a very
different and disturbing picture the
universe isn't cruising it's fighting
for its life it may seem peaceful here
on earth on a nice sunny day but in fact
above us and all around us throughout
the universe a battle is raging and it
has raged since the beginning of time
two deadly forces grapple for control
the first expansion pulls galaxies apart
cooling the universe and threatening it
with a frozen extinction
the second gravity tries to crush
everything back together annihilating
the universe and a dense ball of fire
well gravity or expansion win or will it
end in a tie these two colossal forces
yield three end games
one is the big freeze expansion winds
and the universe just expands forever
the second is that there is a delicate
balance between the expansion and the
amount of gravitational attraction then
universe gets to a particular size and
it pretty much stays there and the third
outcome is that the gravitational
attraction wins and the expansion stops
and the universe begins to get smaller
until eventually it goes back to a Big
Crunch so far the universe seems
balanced on a tightrope between
expansion and contraction but will it
keep its equilibrium until it runs out
of steam or will something tip the
balance